the problem we have here is what  happened to true sperm his sperm was  supposed to be defrosted and it was  supposed to be inseminated that day so  if it didn't go into Christina is there  someone else who he fathered how is this  situation changed their lives  well it's devastated it it's one of the  issues that led to their ultimate  divorce there's so many layers here you  know they were I think they were  struggling to some extent as a married  couple and this put them over the edge  what's the best outcome for you  unfortunately there's no perfect outcome  because you can never go back in time  the best outcome is that this clinic and  other clinics follow suit and change  their procedures and make sure this  never ever happens to another couple